hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're in round
three of our coverage of the 2016 Tata
Steel tournament yesterday we had a
pretty epic match between Fabiana
Caruana
and Magnus Carlsen who the Titans in the
game if you haven't seen that video I
highly recommend you check it out some
really awesome chess but today's match
maybe one of the most anticipated chess
matches in a very long time why it's
gonna be played by none other than 16
year old Chinese Grandmaster e way now
if you're not too familiar with a way
when he was 13 he was the fourth
youngest a grandmaster ever that two of
the players younger than him to become
grandmaster who are in this tournament
one is Sergei cockade the other is
Magnus Carlsen his opponent today Magnus
Carlsen is e-way said is his favorite
player so he gets to play the world
champion his favorite player and many
players are saying that he way has the
potential to surpass Magnus Carlsen in
the game now a little bit on a way that
Tata Steel tournament every year has two
different divisions you have the Masters
group which is what we're covering right
now you have 14 of some of the top
players in the world but you also have a
challenger group these are players that
are extremely talented but they're not
quite at that master level the winner of
that challenger group every year gets to
play in the Masters event next year so
II way one the Challenger group last
year that's why he gets to play in the
Masters group this year but he has just
been dominating the field in March of
2015 he became the youngest player ever
to have a rating of 2,700 and in May of
last year he also became the youngest
Chinese chess champion ever so he is
dominating the field every chess
tournament he plays he is impressing
everyone and Magnus Carlsen has been
asked about a way for a few years now
saying it you know this kid he's kind of
doing everything you did along the same
timeline just a few months older the
Magnus Carlsen when he became a
grandmaster the Magnus Carlsen all he
wants to do is he wants to be the
champion he said that he wants to be a
champion for a very long time and he
recognizes that this kid is kind of the
future of chess and he needs to make
sure that he establishes himself to this
kid playing here that he's kind of the
best so that's kind of the dynamic that
you have go
going on in this game so without further
ado we're gonna get in to one of the
most anticipated chess matches of the
year so we'll go ahead and get into the
game a way starts out with pawn to e4
always like a player that wants to be
pretty aggressive against the world
champion Magnus Carlsen plays pawn to e5
Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop here to b5
getting into the right Lopez line pawn
here to a6 kicking the bishop back
Knight here to f6 castle on the Kings
side
Bishop here to e7 a rook over here to e1
and then pawn here to b5 pretty
interesting because Magnus Carlsen
usually plays the Berlin defense you
know for the past two years I think
that's kind of been his main go-to for
Black's defense here but decides to go
for something a little bit different
castle on the Kings side here and White
has a few options as far as how he wants
to continue this is getting into the
Marshall attack it's a very sharp line
from black gamba ting one of its pawns
to have a very strong attack a lot of
players even Garry Kasparov one of the
greatest chess players of all time for
white usually tries to play the anti
Marshall attack lines because it's the
theory is just so deep you can get into
a lot of trouble as white and so the
anti decline lines are usually something
pawn here to a4 try to break things up a
knight here to c3 those are some of the
most popular the just going down the
Marshall attack lines would be pawn here
to c3 so in this particular moments we
have a way kind of has the decision to
make to we want to kind of make it a
little bit easy on ourselves and play
the anti Marshall attack or do we just
want to go all in and let magnus carlsen
play one of the sharpest lines as black
and just see how we fare against the
world champion this 16 year old decided
to go with that he plays pawn here to c3
into Magnus Carlsen plays pawn here to
d5 the Marshall attack very very strong
sharp line for Magnus Carlsen
it's really just all theory from here
this has been analyzed for many many
many years and it's really tough to see
how even though White's up upon a
material how he really gains a strong
advantage here like to has a huge attack
that he can start to employ so we do
exchange on board pawn here to to d5
Knight takes Knight takes here on e5
after the exchange rook up here to e5
and then pawn here to a c6 now back in
the day it was kind of thought to play
Knight to f6 this was later improved to
play pawn here to c6 keeping the knight
in the center of the board
and now pawn here to d3 and white has
two different options you can play pawn
here to d3 or you could also just play
pawn here to d4 both are completely okay
decides to go ahead and play pawn here
to d3 opening up the board for his dark
squared Bishop to get involved right now
this pawn on c3 is not doing too much
it's just kind of blocking the Knights
getting ready to get involved into the
game if we look on both sides of the
board Magnus Carlsen wants to throw
everything at the King side of white you
know a way no longer has any protection
over here on the King side so that's
where a lot of the attack happens for
Magnus Carlsen on the opposite side
white really has to do two things one he
needs to protect himself on the King
side he can't get overwhelmed but then
later he wants to start to open up on
the Queen side blacks a little bit more
extended with his pond right here so
maybe kind of get behind enemy lines
start to chip away on some of these
weaknesses here and just see what white
can do in this game we see a bishop here
to d6 centralizing that Bishop rook down
here to e1 Bishop here to f5 some Magnus
crafts and doing a really good job of
getting his pieces involved into the
action both of his bishops in the center
of the board Queen over here to f3 as we
kind of talked about white needs to make
sure he protects to the queen or the
king side of the board now Queen over
here to h4 starting the attack here we
have the bishop right here on d6
protecting this pawn here on h2 so a few
different options on how I could
continue you could play pawn here to g3
kind of stopping this attack or you
could just say you know I'm gonna go
ahead and take here on f5 this is
probably a little bit easy for me to
deal with after the Queen takes Hera h2
King over here to f1 Queen down here to
h1 check the King moves get the rook
involved into the game
Bishop up here u3 stopping that we could
see the knight take here after the
Queen's capture the Queen's captured and
this is going to be fine for white we
start to see some material come off the
board both sides are now even in
material this is kind of
easy way out for away and there's a lot
of these in the game that he has the
opportunity to take and he says you know
I don't want to trade off my pieces I
feel pretty confident even against the
world champion so instead I'm just gonna
stop the attack play pawn to g3 I'm
gonna hold on to my material and I'm
gonna keep my Kings tucked in nicely
here on g1 so the Queen comes down here
to h3 and then we see Bishop here to e3
needs to get this dark square Bishop
involved into the game now the knight
can get involved into the game but nice
central square for this bishop here on
III Magnus Carlsen decides to go ahead
and take here on a d3 and white again
has a couple options he could go ahead
and take with his Bishop here on d5
after the pawn takes the Queen could
come up here capture on d5 attacking
that both bishops right here we can see
the rook swing over here this is gonna
be completely fine if he wants to play
this instead he decides to go a
different route and he plays after
Bishop to d3
he just says hey Knight to d2 I'm gonna
give up that Palmateer will go even on
material-wise I'm just gonna continue
developing my pieces I like my board say
and I just want to see what Magnus
Carlsen can throw at me so - crowd
singing continues with Queen up here -
f5 now Bishop to a d4 just getting a
little bit better position for this
Bishop right here and then we see the
rook over here to e8 trying to gain
control of this long vowel right here
and then King up here - D - G - wants to
make sure that there's no shenanigans
back here on the back rank also wants to
make sure he protects this Queen doesn't
have to have as night here on D -
protecting it as well so doing as much
as he can to stay protected but also
controlling his powerful pieces magnus
carlsen now decides to go ahead and take
with this Queen here on f3 the King
captures rook down here to e6 getting
ready to bring his other rook over here
to e8 kind of that double barrel will
see the rook over here to c1 just
getting a little bit more involved into
the game especially if we once start
pushing up with this pawn I does have
his knight protecting that square as
well and his bishop here on a b3 pawn
here to h6 King back here - G - just
getting a little more King safety he
just want to protect this the square
right here from the Queen but after that
he doesn't wanted to have to worry about
anything with the bishops getting
involved the risks getting involved
anything like that as soon as the King
comes back Magnus crossing quickly
played a work over here to g6 starting
to attack put a lot of pressure on this
g3 Square Knight to e4 just centralizing
that night and then the knight comes
over here to f4 as you can probably see
the pawn can take care on f4 because it
is being pinned down by this rook here
on a g6 so instead we see the King come
up here to f3 and both sides can really
start to get their Kings involved into
the game yes there's still tons of
material both sides have three minor
pieces and two rooks but as long as the
Queen's not on the board it's very
difficult for one side to really swarm
the opponent's king unless they just
don't have any minor pieces or major
pieces themselves so a king up here to
f3 getting a lot more involved into the
game protecting this night here on e4 is
completely fun Bishop takes here the
rook takes up here and now the King's
protecting it as well a knight down here
it's a d3 attacking both this pawn here
on a b2 and this rook here on a c1 who
come in here to a d1 and now Knight
taking here on a b2 rook up here to d2
so as we kind of look at material wise
Magnus Carlsen has done a really good
job he was down upon the material and
now he's up a pawn the material so kind
of fought his way back Magnus Carlsen
you know really strong player as we all
know he is the world champion so a
really good position right here it's
very tough to see how he can get this
into a victory white does have the
double bishop pair it is it open board
state so double bishop hair is going to
be much better than maybe a bishop and a
Knights going into the in game so Walt
Magnus Carlsen has a slight edge just a
material-wise white definitely has
enough to counter-attack and have some
sort of attack if either side were to
blender in this position we see madness
calls him bring his bishop down here to
a3 just holding on to this nighty this
nut can't go anywhere right now
you have d3 square kind of blocked off
you have the square here on c4
kind of blocked off a little bit by this
bishop right here so just bring it down
and protect it a little bit we'll see
the bishop come up here to a b6 let me
see the rook swing over here we see
capture now the bishop captures and this
is going to be fine because once this
rook from the D file escapes now it's a
little bit easier than I can come here
to d3 and escape doesn't have to worry
about this bishop dark-squared bishop
kind of protecting that as well a rook
over here to a d2 so attacking both this
night and also attacking this bishop
kind of behind it
blacks kind of forced to come here to e5
check and then after a check we can see
the bishop move if it wants to Bishop
comes back here to e7 the rook can't
swing over here really like to play work
over here to d8 but he way does a nice
little job of having his Bishop here on
b6 stopping the route coming to the most
logical square and that is that the D
file which a way is kind of holding down
with his rook right now so pot up here
to f4 forcing the knight to move knight
comes back here to c4 after the capture
right here we do see a double pawn right
here so even though magnus carlsen is up
upon having the double pawns right here
on the C file it's probably not the best
right here a way brings his rook up here
to the seventh rank as you probably seen
from any of my videos you always want to
get your your rook to the seventh rank
if you're white if you're black and want
to bring it down here to the second rank
you can just get behind your opponent's
pieces start to gobble up some of the
pawns right here also put a lot of
pressure on your opponent's king you
can't really come past the seventh rank
unless he kind of dances around these
pawns so a really nice square for a way
and his rook here on a d7 Bishop here to
f7 f6 attacking the pawn right here rook
over here anyway says okay you can go
ahead and take that I'm gonna go ahead
and take yours but Magnus Carlsen now
has a passed pawn here on the c4 it's
good in bed the good news is he has a
passed pawn it's who he's gonna look to
push that pawn that's his plan a B and C
the problem is that his opponent has a
dark square bishop and this pawn would
actually promote to a dark square and
this is something that even in your own
games you should look at if you're
passed pawn is going to promote to a
square where your opponent can't stop it
with a bishop
that is significantly stronger than if
your opponent could actually stop it
with his bishop because they could just
hang out all day long if they wanted to
just wait till you promote and just take
that no harm no foul for them so it's
not as big of an advantage as it
probably looks up but Magnus Carlsen
definitely wants to be pushing this pawn
as much as possible Magnus Carlsen plays
rook over here to b8 attacking the
bishop there on a b6 pawn up here to a4
starting to push Bishop over here to be
to Bishop here to a5 pretty interesting
decides to go ahead and give up this
pawn here on a c3 after the bishop takes
the bishop recaptures and then the rook
takes here so both sides are equal in
material going into the rook in game
completely even right now that no side
is is up at all definitely kind of looks
like a draw game but really just decide
if anyone's going to make a mistake or
how this kind of goes from here so rook
down here to be for attacking the pawn
pawn comes up here to a5 and that's fine
work here to be 5 and then swinging the
rope over here to a3 protecting that and
then you just sign it kind of see a
little bit of dancing rook down here to
be to just forcing that the King to move
a pawn here to f5 kind of improving
position Luke over here to c3 and I
thought this was somewhat interesting
there's just nowhere for the this rook
to really go but he plays you know rook
here to c3 a rook here to b5 rook back
here to a3 holding on to that pond then
we start to see some action on the King
side magnus carlsen sees kind of a
weakness that he can start to attack on
the Kings side so he starts to push
forward pawn here to g5 after the take
right here King back here - g2 now
magnus carlsen finally gets his King
involved into the game upon a beard h4
and pawn to g4 this is somewhat
interesting for Magnus Carlsen because
now White has a past Potter protect the
best pawn that he can start to push
forward and this is now a threat that a
way has they would take a lot to
actually push this all the way up the
board but it definitely still represents
a threat on board that he has now we see
rook over here to a c4 which is
interesting that he decides to go ahead
and give up this pawn on a5 I probably
would have played rook here to a
four makes a lot of sense just keep it
on board he could have always played
King here to f2 if he wanted to that
that looks fine to me as well but I
decided to go and play rook here to c3
now the rook takes here on a5 look up
here to c6 work down here forcing the
King to move on now pawn here to 85 and
then rook over here to 86 but this is
kind of where a way once to have his
rook for the rest of the game if he can
it forces this pawn right here it can't
really do anything as soon as this rook
were to move he could just take this
pawn doesn't really matter where it is
on the a rank this King right here can
never come back to sixth ranks it's
completely blocked off by this rook if
he wants to we can even start to push
forward with this pawn here on the
h-file so e-way although he's down the
material he really likes his position
not necessarily for the win but he
recognizes that magnus carlsen really
can't do anything in this position from
here magnus carlsen and says say okay I
have a passed pawn there's nothing else
I can really do here so I'm gonna go
ahead and push that pawn King here to h1
King here to f7 King kind of moves
around a little bit so we do see some
twofold repetition then all of a sudden
we see the King move here to e7 doesn't
want to have the threefold repetition
yet a king here - h1 a3 and then King
here - g1 and in this particular case
Magnus Carlsen decides okay I'm gonna go
ahead and extend my hand for the draw
there's just no way even though he's up
opponent material there's no way he can
actually win this game you know II was
just gonna keep his king over here he's
not even gonna to worry about his pawn
pushing forward and as as we said before
as soon as this rook moves this pawns
gonna fall his King can get involved
nothing good is really gonna come from
it just a lot of time waste if they
continue to move on so both players
shake hands a drawing game a really
exciting though we don't see a lot of a
way I haven't covered a lot of his
matches before so to see the sixteen
year old kid play against Magnus Carlsen
his hero who he said is the best chess
player in the world
he played extremely well he didn't shy
away from one of the sharpest lines in
the right Lopez the Marshall attack
there was a few opportunities where he
easily taking the easy way and gone for
a quick drawl but he said I'm gonna take
the more aggressive rod I'm gonna keep
on to my material and I think I actually
have the possibility to win now
in the end magnus carlsen I think did
enough to kind of go up in material
fortunately wasn't able to win the game
for his sake but both sides played
extremely well I think Manish Carlsen
recognized that hey this
sixteen-year-old kid is legit but this
match been highly anticipated our really
enjoyed covering it excited to see more
from a way both in this tournament and
then later on I think he's going to be
doing great things so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this tournament hopefully you
enjoyed this match definitely one of the
more exciting ones so far even if it was
a draw but I'll see you guys in the next
round
thanks for watching